county students summer is over back to
school on monday and we're going to help
you start the school year off right
with style tips melinda sheckles uh the
editor of
off the strip dot com is here to share a
few
must have essentials welcome to the show
hi jc it's been too long i know
it's great to be back in the studio so
what are we going to start with what do
you have for us
okay so fashion show has a bunch of
really cool stuff going on for the kids
they're actually going to be doing
weekly activations around different
movies so they start this week
and while you're there you can pick up
some great back-to-school items
like vans oh bands okay so all the kids
i asked a panel of children what they
want to be wearing at school
and they said it's all about vans and
hoodies so vans has these
comfy kush they're like a cloud wash
and then they have amazing
glow-in-the-dark ones for the boys that
are so cool so you get a cloud wash
comfy kush
and then you get glow-in-the-dark you
get all the vans are so cool i mean
they're so classic we were advanced
martial
back in the day we wear vans now um so
okay so cool at fashion show now you can
also
jump on over to nordstrom
as well so nordstrom has all the cool
adidas
oh nice so you can get your adidas
jackets you can get your adidas track
suits you can get
so many different again another cloud
wash so popular
for the girls and for the boys camo
cloud wash
all the pretty colors and you can also
check them out there's great adidas
selection actually at downtown summerlin
as well
at the nordstrom's rack oh it is perfect
they're so cool all right what's the
next thing you got for okay so lunches
everybody's always talking about their
lunches their bento boxes you can look
at it on tick tock you can look at it
on all over the internet so bentology is
the bento box lunchbox maker you can
order these online
they range in price from like 16 to like
25
super cool patterns so you get a llama
you can also get the octopus pattern a
bunch of different
types of styles they make all of the
different bento box containers so you
can also use them for crafts as well in
addition to lunches that is better than
my he-man lunch box that i had that is
kind of cool what are some other
accessories you got for us today okay so
we've got some really cool accessories
now everybody knows we always want hand
sanitizer around obviously
hand sanitizer handy guru this is such a
cool company you can have your hand
sanitizer
right on your wrist kids can just use it
there
always stay clean and sanitized and then
okay we all love a planner
i know i'm old school i still use a
planner same here
the go get em girl planner is so cool
they come in multiple colors
you know really it's all about women's
empowerment very very cool little
planner that you can get for girls you
can get it for boys i mean whoever you
want to get it for
great to plan out all your activities in
there and i love the name of the company
go get a girl
and many different colors yeah one more
thing about anxiety i believe okay so if
you
if you can't bring your pet with you you
can have the anxiety pillow this lumira
anxiety pillow you can actually put a
heartbeat it has a
a box in it you can put it it has a
heartbeat and a warmer so it could be
just like your your doctor that is
perfect thank you so much melinda you
always have great stuff
i appreciate it thanks jc las vegas